[Music]
Tracy I mentioned Khloe Kardashian
earlier in the show you you said that
you're a big fan of the show Khloe and
Lamar is that right yeah we just
recently found out our test results came
back she's my daughter Khloe is your
daughter it could have been OJ's it was
a threesome I met the mom Chrissy up in
relays in Philadelphia okay for some
reason she was at a relay race huh we
spoke on the phone and she loves daddy
okay this is a huge revelation you men's
be all over the deck listen I'm
Hollywood royalty people a lot of people
don't know that I'm a descendant of
Clark Gable your descendant that's why
I'm do a lot of swashbuckle know Michael
Clark Gable
yeah so that proves it yeah you see yeah
Carol used to do this yeah yeah when he
was painting his barn yeah
[Laughter]
is it true that your favorite movie of
all time we're gonna talk about classic
movies your favorite movie of all time
Oh yours is Planet of the Apes the
original Planet of the yeah yeah that's
my great-great uncle starred in it Chuck
Heston was so crazy I was a baby so I
grew up on the set and he will come pick
me up in his car and I'll be sitting in
my own dog food shop Chuckie
Charlie has chuckles I guess that proves
it then then you called him Chuck yeah
he was crazy he be driving around I
[Laughter]
[Music]
wanna ask you about your life personal
life you'll have moved to New Jersey is
that right yeah like in New Jersey I
never lived in new it is nice I live in
Alpine over there in Alpine and I'm
Katie Couric keep calling me talk about
so you want to come over Katie Couric
wants to come here cuz I'll be
barbecuing I got big pan of pig feet on
stove now this is barbecuing in the
house hops yes
I'm cooking song but barbecue all over
it but barbecue is so much now man ever
since Obama became president gas prices
went down on barbecue sauce look through
the roof
so that president I knew that was going
happening
so barbecues more expensive now you
bring you a new pole cigarettes Newport
cigarettes tell you Michelle won't get
pregnant in that White House second term
he thinks I know he tuning her off ain't
a little hair colorful men in his hair
he's on the younger get random random
she's got me pregnant he's gonna be
giving a state of this state of the will
you call that Union instead of the Union
speech I don't keep up with politics
State of the Union speech and she gonna
be standing right behind a pregnant
Chicago oh this baby's kicking is wrong
with you I'm over here
come on man you know about his new book
that just came out no he did Co what's
yeah the new book - I was all over the
news he did cocaine where he was over
there in college and stuff and he said
he did it enthusiastically who doesn't
do it busy drink heavily and all that
other stuff like I sold it all I don't
have to say where I want a transcript of
this interview I'm gonna go through it
and find out what the hell happened here
what the heck